alors en présentant ses propositions
monsieur chevènement qui n'a pas voulu
remplacer le projet savary par un autre
portant son nom a voulu plutôt mettre un
terme au combat idéologique et concilier
comme il le dit lui-même le libre choix
par les parents de l'éducation qu'il
souhaite donner à leurs enfants tout en
respectant les principes du service
public et l'esprit de la
décentralisation en france monsieur
chevènement interrogé par notre
spécialiste dominique le rock
l'essentiel pour la france c'est
d'investir dans l'éducation c'est ça qui
est absolument fondamental il y à une
école publique qui scolarise huit jeunes
français sur dix il y à des
établissements privés qui le cas échéant
peuvent concourir au service public de
l'enseignement il n'y a pas de
mathématiques catholique mais il est
important que l'école publique joue tout
son rôle du point de vue de l'unité
nationale parce que l'école publique
c'est quand même l'endroit où les petits
français se rencontrent et l'école
communale sur la place de nos villages
c'est à peu une institution
je crois aussi qu'il est importante pour
lutter contre l'inégalité pour donner
aux jeunes y compris de milieux
populaires des chances égales d'accès au
savoir et c'est la raison pour laquelle
le gouvernement entend mettre le paquet
si je puis dire sur la rénovation du
système éducatif est d'abord de l'école
publique et pourtant vous avez donné
satisfaction également l'enseignement
privé je suis parti de choses simples
j'ai fait des propositions comme je les
dis ce sont des bus simple pratique des
mesures de progrès
qui se trouvait pour beaucoup d'entre
elles d'ailleurs dans le projet de loi
de monsieur savary je suis heureux de
voir que
ces mesures sont de nature à ramener la
paix civile la france en a besoin n'ont
pas les moyens de nous perdre dans des
querelles qui échappent d'ailleurs au
plus grand nombre j'en suis convaincu et
la laïcité dans tout ça bien de laïcité
c'est une chose très belle et est très
simple cela veut dire que la république
créée par tous des écoles pour tous les
jeunes français quelle que soit leur
religion ou même s'ils n'ont pas su aux
catholiques juifs protestants
musulmans et que tous les jeunes
français peuvent se rencontrer dans
cette école peuvent apprendre ont un
égal accès aux savoirs et ses écoles
respecte leur liberté de conscience
c'est absolument fondamental pour
l'unité nationale pour l'unité du pays
et je dirais que du point de vue de la
démocratie
il faut aussi s'intéresser aux enfants
des milieux les couches populaires pour
leur donner des moyens de réussir leur
vie pour leur donner les moyens de la
promotion et c'est pas seulement leurs
intérêts elle c'est l'intérêt du pays la
plus grande chance de la france c'est sa
matière grise c'est l'intelligence
aujourd'hui c'est notre atout
fondamental alors il faut le mettre en
valeur de la manière la plus intensif
seul ministre un dernier mot mais pas le
sentiment qu'on a perdu trois ans je ne
pense pas je crois que il faut être
juste vous savez le projet de monsieur
savary et est ambitieux mais il a
beaucoup travaillé monsieur savary et il
n'a pas toujours été bien compris on a
fait beaucoup de procès d'intention
combien de ceux qui ont manifesté dans
la rue qui avaient vraiment lu le projet
de monsieur savard et soyons francs la
vérité c'est que c'est aussi parce que
monsieur savard y avait beaucoup
travaillé que j'ai pu faire rapidement
des propositions
de mesures simples et pratiques